CBS Films Daniel Radcliffe's attempt to
shake Harry Potter is ruined by the
movie's second logo which reminds us of
the train to Hogwarts and the important
information he's likely sharing with
Hermione and Ron on it fictional tea
also tea party is symbolic of American
Tea Party serving empty cups - brainless
human look-alikes come on how much force
can a seven-year-old girls slow motion
foot step have it's not like they're
stomping they're just walking woman in
black looks out and gets three windows
to pull off this symmetrical horror
suicide on a girl in the middle got a
head start
foggy glimpses of a wedding and a
pregnancy during the opening credits
makes me wish they could have applied
thicker fog so I didn't have to see that
jeez his wife is dead he's got overdue
bills and his kids still alive
how much misfortune does this guy have
anyway also quick flask shot and a
glance at an overdue bill give you 80%
of this character's backstory and one
five-second shot child draws sad or
disturbing family pictures in a horror
movie cliche just like your mother who
is dead
will offer not charity wait what
then the stack of overdue bills
basically say you weren't paying him any
money anyway this is your final warning
as if the money we weren't giving you is
not enough warning movie cuts from Harry
Potter to a train shot expects me not to
have a people fit well you just go ahead
and tell us his wife died during
childbirth already I wish I still had
that cliche boy very sorry mr. caps I
agree that he should have gotten the
news about the baby first but damn they
waited an awful long time to spring the
bad news on him didn't they also Kip's
has been in a funk for four years
basically blowing off work to be sad for
that amount of time
why isn't he already fired and I can
give you a list it's on my way oh thank
you
rides from strangers the hotel dude
doesn't want to give kids his room which
makes you wonder why the hotel take the
reservation in the first place what do
they learn about a name in a reservation
in the last few days how would they
learn anything about it faster than a
train trowels how did they learn his
name was even somehow connected to an
investigation at the creepy house or
does this asshole just generally
distrust any outsider and I'm back to
asking why'd they even take the
reservation in the first place also even
if it's true didn't Sam Daly tell Arthur
that he didn't see many visitors around
this place well we don't get to see many
faces it's hard to believe that this end
would ever be so packed if that were the
case this way no payment of any kind
will be required and either everyone in
this bring down somehow knows Kip's and
the reason he's here or everyone in this
town is a dick to everyone
husband went to meet you at the Gifford
arms and here he is like magic also
obviously since you're psychic we
figured you know he went to meet you
with the it so we took no measures
whatsoever to make sure you didn't walk
all the way over here also in such a
small town and with everyone knowing who
Arthur is by sight it's hard to believe
that her husband didn't see him on the
way over to the end
Adeiny spec to be finished until Friday
at least but you are finished talking
despite your lip still obviously moving
after you said that my head just went to
the outside of my language so you went
into his attic room packed his
belongings in his bag and took them wow
this house that everyone in town is
really spooked and concerned about isn't
remotely close to town any town oh look
there's the place where Harry and
Dumbledore found the first Horcrux Jesus
this movie is blatantly trading on Harry
Potter imagery for subconscious audience
goodwill half of this movie is Daniel
Radcliffe walking into some empty house
or room and looking around at things
also this woman has been dead for one
month and there are a terrifying number
of cobwebs everywhere in this house you
know I was perfectly fine standing here
looking in a completely different
direction but now for nobody's benefit
except anyone who might be watching I'll
turn to my left because it's good to get
exercise the dirty water coming out of
this faucet is fresher than this jump
scare this is exactly like the pile of
letters my college girlfriend wrote me
only less on fire time that covers the
only road to the creepy house ends up
not being a real factor at all in the
plot of this film one year olds can't
read 19th century seven-year-old did not
have an occupation yet what a lazy
bastard even at 19 whatever year it is
how can an official cause of death be
drowning when no body was recovered
noises upstairs in the creepy house no
wonder this movie had a sequel
he's even holding a small wand salmonela
jump scarecrow ah long distance nuns he
thinks he's on a disappearing ghost
woman so naturally he storms right
outside to confront said mystical beam
right before he went outside he looked
out the window and there were a couple
of patches of fog but now totally
immersive fog because we don't know how
to horror otherwise what was wrong with
this asshole did he not want to call out
to Arthur to tell him he was here a guy
like this who was scared of this place
would definitely not get out of his
carriage just so he could be a
jump-scare dick no one is used now in
love causeway for years how is that
possible how did anyone know that alice
drablow was even dead
how did Arthur's lawfirm know for a fact
that there were documents they needed to
get out of the house Alice didn't like
visitors she obviously didn't go to town
often or at all and she had no relatives
and to be someone using the causeway to
know all this
this poster offers a reward for
something about gardens and vegetables
I'm taking it that the important
information is buried in the small print
hmm do I send the jump-scare via blood
puking or the blood puking girl who
drank law I just happens to be escorted
into the police station while Arthur is
there briefed mimicking he's taco al
nosh house wine - keeps you said you
have a son okay look you can't tell
someone not to go to a house all spooky
like and then not answer the damn
question when they naturally ask why the
house should be avoided also doesn't
Arthur have all the documents he needs
does he even need to stay here can he go
back to London and conduct all the
business he needs to conduct its
paperwork I heard about the girl in the
village my wife doesn't know and I'd be
grateful if you could avoid the subject
indeed the subject of children all
together so now let's have dinner in the
room where there's reminders of our dead
son everywhere and we'll assume that my
wife will not be the least bit curious
about you and won't bring up the subject
herself also this dude just asked hips
not to talk about kids and yet his house
is nothing but pictures and paintings of
his dead son who he himself is now
talking about Elizabeth no she's done
this before and you never committed to
shutter island' ah whatever year this is
when chloroform was considered medicine
what a time to be alive
then they chloroform the dogs - because
why not I saw it some company would do
good considering the narrow amount of
topics you could talk about without her
going crazy and knifing the table this
was a silly thing to think just in case
you didn't get the idea that mrs. Daley
treats her dogs like human children here
she is after a chloroforming tucking the
dogs into a crib with the door wide open
so that any asshole can walk by and see
it I'll lose my job before I get this
paperwork done it's something I could do
on the train back to London but I need
to stay here to do it and unearth all
the horror I can find
well this movies been pretty consistent
so far with the jump scares this is a
jump scare waiting to happen right how
does this scene happen all these people
live inside the town but they're all
outside the town waiting for Arthur and
mr. Gailey to drive back out instead of
just waiting for them by the car when
they were in Jerome's house so how did
they all gather so quickly Arthur and
Sam drove to the house the girl screamed
at them and in two minutes they're
driving out and there's a mob waiting
for them all of a sudden also one of
these guys has drawn himself did he not
have one bit of concern about Arthur
showing up to the house while his
daughter was there all alone you should
have left you should have gone when we
told your trophy you should have given
him even 5% of a decent reason instead
of just telling him to go
and he might have actually left wait he
didn't bring any of that paperwork back
with him when he was here the first time
I would want light to but Kip's lights
enough candles to nearly guarantee a
house fire don't worry about me just
slapping my hand on the window
want me to cook you some eggs I make
great eggs it's almost like this thing
only exists so that they could get a
cool shot and a jump scare out of it let
the sight of me be a contract for our
now implied relationship I'll just with
you for a while but I'll kill you later
than sooner for unknown reasons Saavik
he's still gonna go in that house after
this isn't he they told you human
curiosity is not this strong haven't you
ever heard of Maslow's hierarchy of
needs
it's self-actualization esteem well
safety and then physiological needs and
then somewhere way after that it comes
curiosity Jesus great you are now
exactly where the ghost apparition
wanted you to be and for some reason
you're looking for the ghost thing to be
where you were standing earlier are you
looking at I don't see anything oh well
tell you later
also this movies ghosts need to make up
their mind as to whether or not Harry
Potter can see them for no good reason
at all Kipps decides to open the window
seat and what do you know he finds
plot-related
in there and great more paperwork I
think we've seen what the true horror is
in this movie yeah
I find it hard to express the depth of
betrayal from you my own sister that you
refuse all to them me visit my son or
even give him my birthday cards okay but
the paper he looked at a second ago says
this letter was written late 1800s a
time during which I think it would be
difficult to know whether or not someone
else has given the mail you sent to
another someone else how can he even
read this I'll never forgive you
wrote in how what about the sentence
just before rot in hell that ends in the
word die see it there to the left
how come the voiceover letter writing
narrator death chick didn't say that
sentence I think this door needs to be
open Oh II think this door needs to be
open tip starts to fall asleep literally
two seconds after leaning back this dog
growls but doesn't do anything more
until the woman in black gets within
killing distance um the ghost definitely
didn't have time to scratch out these
eyes before the dog barked get the out
of this house
the stall does not approve of Arthur's
redecorating skills
neither does Rafiki from The Lion King
nor even this monocled monkey geez
what's her problem also I want to give
the movie points just for finally
letting Kip see some go ship but it's a
jump-scare so I still have to call it a
sin
well the knocking on the door is surely
the recently risen from the dead kid so
why are you walking toward the door
who's that ghosts who were obviously
trying to scare this asshole stop doing
the scary when yells who's there
why would you do this the kids from
sinister are not amused oh now he's
gonna run away from the scary after
spending the entire movie going towards
it I went upstairs got scared went
outside got scared came back inside time
to go back upstairs those who forget
history are doomed to repeat it all
muddy kid wanted was to play with his
toys in the room where that woman hang
herself and then this asshole shows up
and set up doing his paperwork
bedwetting why does this dar baby have
to be born through the sheets of the bed
instead of I don't know just making an
appearance does it no it needs to be
theatrical because it's in a movie this
asshole is conveniently waiting to pick
Kipps up as he's fleeing the house in
terror obvious green screen driving
scene is obvious of course maybe that's
just what the ghosts wanted us to see
stay that I'm gonna come and get you
let's talk about the woman in Black's
plan she basically sits around rocking
in her chair at the eel marsh house and
enjoys an angry yet peaceful ghostly
existence but if someone sees her she's
like out dare you I'm going to the
nearest town to make children there kill
themselves nearly in one entire minute
of grieving over a kid we thought was
kind of a dick anyway whenever she's
been seeing however briefly and whoever
by that has always been one sure
uncertain result okay but who in this
town has seen her did they get alienated
by the town too what is the history of
woman in black sightings also why did
none of the townspeople tell him why he
shouldn't go to the house lives are on
the line but they're all scared of
telling him like the woman in black is
from Baltimore or something they took
her boy away so now she takes us but
only if someone goes to her house and
Cesar there is that caveat she made both
these kids kill themselves and then
these three kids but these two kids she
left alone when the girl drank the line
she really is kind of a picky ghost
didn't she if we
reunite Janet Humphrey with her son
perhaps we'll finally be at peace or she
won't have a feeling it's just my face
Arthur decides to do something insane
that might cause his death and probably
won't even work if he succeeds a father
boy and he's remarkably undie composed
and the woman in black left them both
alone while Kipps washed every bit of
mud off himself and the other two did
shots does Arthur know what the hell
he's doing does law school teach you
about the rituals to reunite a dead son
with his dead mother I guess this movie
skipped the go to the library seen that
so many of these horror movies do which
is totally fine I just want to know how
he thinks that winding up these toys is
a necessary step in the ghost reunion
and the sky drinks at tonk and he's the
only guy who owns a car in this area so
if he ever needs a designated driver
he's fuck damn that sprinkler systems
gone haywire again that's all the things
I get for digging your kid out of the
mud a whore and she's gone she's been
gone several times and she always comes
back why is this any different if you
were gonna do this anyway I don't know
why you went through all the trouble
with the kid and his birthday cards in
the windup toys that literally could
have been a total waste of time and as
far as I know you have no way of
confirming that it wasn't I still don't
know why even if she never forgave her
sister for her son dying why that means
everyone else had to suffer too and that
we're don't look at me rule that will
never get explained until maybe the
sequal bills about the tanks tripods on
there can you fetch us some tickets
probably not since it's like the middle
of the night right they made a big deal
out of him missing the last train to
London earlier in the movie it's getting
late you'll miss your London train but
no it's like I don't know a lot of
clocked
Wolfgang schmoovy after the muddy dead
boy body burying hell he just went
through to protect his son there is no
fucking way this father is nonchalantly
letting go of his son's hand now both of
these men should be paying extra
attention to this child's whereabouts
after the evening they had your mommy oh
so it's a happy ending woohoo
I mean I guess it beats paperwork yeah
we're all dead as long as we have each
other I guess we should be thanking the
woman in black for putting Arthur's kid
directly in front of that train man I
hope they don't do that thing where the
horror villain suddenly turns to the
camera
god dammit also go spritz the fourth
wall and fix the illusion up for
everyone thanks ghost bitch
that's nanny nots mummy get mummy now
plane up in the sky strength through
unity unity through faith I'm a
god-fearing English man on a dark damn
proud of it so what was Draco down
without weird-looking cabinet and who
are all those people so you know how to
take the reservation you just don't know
how to hold
what happened to you and then you're
defending ol galaxy and suddenly you
find yourself sucking down Darjeeling
with Marie Antoinette and Richard women
holy smokes is that you huh as I live
and breathe these letters have just now
been delivered to mr. Kringle by bona
fide employees of the post office
you